I don't want to do the same type of
movie over and over again I completely
identified with that thing that happens
inside all of us when we have to do
something creative because what's the
point of doing all this hard work if
it's not appreciated because that's the
art form I was horrible I was that was
the worst experience in my mi in my
career it was just I was just horrible
directing is waking up every morning and
compromising he's an American filmmaker
and screenwriter he's credited as being
one of the greatest visual storytellers
in filmmaking he's directed some of the
biggest blockbuster hits over the last
few decades he's Robert Zemeckis and
here is my take on his top ten rules for
success number eight is my personal
favorite and I'm curiously figure out
which one you guys like the best all I
want to do is are good scripts
however they have to manifest themselves
have you ever had an agenda have you
ever been I never had that mindset I
never have I've never had like I'm too
Restless I could no here's what I
thought I don't know what I want to do
but I know what I don't want to do is
that what I can answer the question like
that I don't want to do the same type of
movie over and over again mm-hmm I
wouldn't want to just be doing comedies
I wouldn't want to just be doing
suspense movies or action movies I would
I mean I would that way I mean I always
want to like mix it up why did you
decide to give this tribute not only to
Philippe Petit but also to the sense of
freedom and follow your dreams in a way
exactly for that reason I mean I
completely identified with that thing
that happens inside all of us when we
have to do something creative and that
thing that happens when you have a
passion and you have a dream and you
have to follow that dream at all costs I
think it's a very universal story I
think we all feel that in some level and
that's why I thought it was that
everyone could identify with this
character when I when I decide to make a
film I have to make it you know I have
that it that that there's that Drive
inside of me that passion
that dream that I have to realize the
film and I completely understand that if
you spend a lot of time assembling a
team of really really talented artists
who are also reasonable people then the
the the best way to make a film is to
collaborate and to take good ideas from
from everybody and you know rejecting
that you know that you the the hardest
thing to do is when you open when you
open your your your set up to
collaboration what you don't want to do
is you don't want to hurt people's
feelings when you reject their ideas but
that is so but basically as a director
my feeling is is I'll take a good idea
from anybody and you know I'll I'll very
you know often ask everyone for help
you know I'll sit here and say okay I
don't I don't know what to do but then
but then at the end of the day you're
the one responsible to getting the work
done and so you have to ultimately you
know make decisions to keep everything
moving forward so I know that that's
kind of a long-winded answer but I but I
think if you said what is your directing
style it's much more collaborative than
it is dictatorial so for you how much of
the judgment of whether you were happy
with what finally came out is about you
and how much is it about the idea of an
audience having that experience are you
and I you mean is it is reaction to the
movie as important to you as your own
satisfaction with what you did yeah I
mean well it's a close second because
because what's the point of doing all
this hard work if it's not appreciated
because that's the art form the art form
is to be exhibited to a mass audience so
if I you know it's not like writing up
writing poetry which I love but that's a
different art form so I guess what I'm
saying is is that
every movie has to has to satisfy two
criteria for me first is is this a movie
that I would like to see hmm
that's number one and if that's yes then
the next question right alongside is and
is this a movie I think anybody else
would like to see and if that's a yes
then those are the only two criteria I
can't think of anything else everything
else is up to the movie gods you guys
included it on the back to the future of
series but on the later DVDs but it was
on the internet before that the idea of
he's shot it with Eric Stoltz yeah but I
had nothing to do with this ability it
was there there is a situation where you
know Eric is a brilliant actor I mean we
loved my whole thing it's just that I
simply I simply miss cast them and I
learned a very serious lesson and you
know it's like it's it's not worth it's
too painful for everybody what you have
to do is you have to cast the movie the
right way and feel really right about it
otherwise don't go down that road he was
a great actor though resident great
absolutely great little tactic with a
little cover just so people can see that
Eric Stoltz was Martin a flat one point
he just said I don't think we're getting
the laughs that I was hoping we would
get and and I looked at Bob and I
realized that he was absolutely correct
and I said Bob what do you want to do so
I had to make this horrific decision
which was very heartbreaking for
everybody yeah and that's rough yeah
stuff was a director who's the leader of
when you sit down and tell the actor
what was that like telling that was
gonna replace them yeah that was
horrible I was that was the worst
experience in my in my in my career it
was just it was just horrible it was
like you know never want to do that
again well I always loved going to the
cinema to see action and special effects
I love seeing horror movies I love seen
monster movies I love seeing war movies
you know when I grew up there was many
World War two movies and I loved
watching movies to see the action and
the special effects but it wasn't until
I was in high school when I was about 13
years old and I saw a film it was a
Arthur Penfield called Bonnie and Clyde
and I remember feeling my emotions being
you know move up and being moved by the
film and I remember having a vivid
thought at that point that I was
thinking wow this is this is very
interesting this is this is sort of an
amazing power and from that moment on I
then I started to learn what a that Oh
films have directors and I learned the
process of how films are made and then
fell in love with the the art form and
from so since I was 13 all I ever wanted
to do was make films and it's the only
thing I know how to do so so I can't do
anything else so correcting is waking up
every morning and compromising hmm you
have this idea this ideal of what you
want to do that day and you then you
know you just
it just gets stripped away and stripped
away and stripped away in stripped away
except for those magnificent moments
when the cast does something that you
couldn't imagine and you go wow that is
really awesome and then you immediately
get a feeling of dread because you're
expecting then as soon as you say cut
that someone will say yeah we missed the
focus there was a boom in the shot there
was an extra in the background who
tripped and fell whatever whatever the
thing is that ruined the moment that you
may not get back again
he saw the two towers and he literally
drew a pencil line between the two
towers and said I've got to put a wire
between those towers I got a walk it's
like you know in his mind he believes
that those towers were built for him to
create this performance just like he
felt that notre-dame was for him no tree
Dom was for him and what's amazing about
Philippe and why I think his story is
unique but yet it's a universal story is
that that's what happens to all artists
you know you ask an artist why did you
do this why did you paint this painting
why did you make this movie why did you
write this music there's never any
answer for it it just I just something I
have to do and anyone who creates any
type of art and we all do so we all have
our own artistic expression will
identify with with that thing that was
inside Philippe where he had to do this
no matter what I've always well Maya
values giving the same advice I think
that the the the premium thing the thing
that is the the most valuable thing the
thing we don't have enough of his ideas
and screenplays so my my recommendation
is to always write not only do I believe
that that's the most like I said just
now is that is that that's the most
valuable commodity in the industry is to
have a good screenplay I think it's also
what makes you into a good filmmaker no
no I've never regretted any movie I've
ever passed on huh ever really ever and
anyone you've ever made never no not one
I'm proud of all love them all so you're
very happy man content Happy's dangerous
work you know you know some what content
you know happy is a very dangerous word
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because our Bibby Rodriguez
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you I made a profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd love to know
which of the top ten rules had the
biggest impact on you and why what
lesson are you gonna adopt and apply now
to your business or life leave it in the
comments
and I will join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon